jeden tag passieren auch der welt
unzählige faszinierende dinge und es ist
wichtig sie zu verstehen und
wissenschaft ist die einzige methode um
das zu ermöglichen und die steht bei
klicks um science-fiction im mittelpunkt
herzlich willkommen eine these eine
theorie oder hypothese gelangte in unser
bewusstsein und dann wird sie immer und
immer wieder überprüft und schließlich
bestätigt und nur wenn sie dem stand
hält dann wissen wir dass sie unsere
realität beschreibt das ist immer für
die menschheit ein riesending wie zum
beispiel bei der relativitätstheorie
alle ihre vorhersagen wurden bestätigt
wie es jüngst die gravitationswellen und
basierend auf diesen erkenntnissen
können wir weiter forschen und gelangen
zu neuem wissen das ist der kern das
herz unserer zivilisation
wenn wir von diesem weg abweichen dann
landen wir wieder im mittelalter und
sind verheerenden solchen
naturkatastrophen und kosmischen
ereignissen hilflos ausgeliefert
nur eines kann uns bewahren wissen
erworben durch wissenschaft wir
berichten darüber hier auf klicks um
science-fiction in videos aus allen
erdenklichen bereichen wir gehen an die
grenzen und zeigen auch die pfade ins
ungewisse auf denn wir wollen unsere
begeisterung für diese themen mit euch
teilen und euch so immer mit den
neuesten nachrichten den spannendsten
ideen entwicklungen und studien
versorgen wir glauben fest daran
man braucht keinen doktor der physik um
die faszination von schwarzen löchern
supernovae oder raketen antrieben zu
teilen und man muss kein diplom in
maschinenbau haben um die neuesten
fortschritte des hyper lob oder bei
tesla spannend zu finden
die berichterstattung über wissenschaft
raumforschung die umwelt physik oder
medizin ist für alle menschen wichtig
denn sie lässt uns die welt verstehen
dafür steht unser kanal und damit du
wenn du uns hier unterstützen wir freuen
uns über jeden wie jedes auto jeden der
uns auf whatsapp und den anderen
messengern folgt und natürlich gehen die
freiwillig beiträge auf kathrin leisten
dadurch werden wir unabhängiger von
youtube und den werbeeinnahmen mit der
unterstützung auf kathrin können wir
durch eure mitarbeiter in der redaktion
nicht nur noch
besser herausfinden welche themen euch
am meisten interessieren sondern haben
auch die finanziellen mittel klicks um
weiter zu verbessern seid gespannt
es wird noch einiges passieren nähere
infos findet ihr auf kathrin der link
ist oben in unserem kanal banner oder
einfach mit patchen und klicks im netz
suchen und an dieser stelle schon mal
einen riesen dank an alle die uns dort
unterstützen bis dann bleibt dran